à moscou la bourse à a dévissé elle a
fermé ses portes le moan la monnaie le
rouble a perdu 40% de sa valeur après
les sanctions occidentales l'a dit
martine dit se concentrer ce lundi sur
la réponse économique a apporté en
recevant notamment les principaux
acteurs de la finance russe on en parle
avec vous j'ai leader golfe bonjour vous
êtes à moscou le président russe veut
envoyer un message clair sa priorité
c'est de contrer l'effet des sanctions
oui il est en réunion d'ailleurs en ce
moment une réunion d'urgence une réunion
de crise avec les différents acteurs du
site fait système financier notamment et
bien le directeur de la banque centrale
russe il a introduit cette réunion en
disant qu'il les avait convoquées je
cite pour répondre aux sanctions de
lempire du mensonge c'est comme ça qu'il
nomme les occidentaux un peu plus tôt
dans la journée le porte parole du
kremlin dimitri peskov avait indiqué
qu'en effet vladimir poutine allait pas
consacré une partie de sa journée à
répondre à ces sanctions économiques il
a indiqué que ces sanctions poser un
problème un bien sûr pour l'économie
russe mais que l'économie russe était
capable d'y répondre un peu plus tôt
dans la journée c'est la banque centrale
russe qui a pris différentes mesures
pour répondre à cette crise économique
et notamment il a fait passer son taux
directeur de manière historique de 9 5%
à 20% c'est vraiment un changement
historique la dernière fois qu'il y
avait eu un taux directeur à peu près
semblable c'était lors lors de la guerre
en crimée il était à 17% alors c'est là
pour but est bien de sauvegarde et
l'épargnent dans les banques et éviter
bien un mouvement de panique qui ferait
que les épargnants retirent leur argent
des banques s'y serait évidemment
catastrophique et puis le ministre des
finances russe à lui quant à lui imposé
aux entreprises exportatrices et bien de
vendre 80 % de leurs devises étrangères
pour acheter du rouble donc vous voyez
c'est une grande période d'incertitude
qui s'ouvre ici en russie d'un point de
vue économique alors julie comment
réagit la population à toutes ces
annonces justement
écouter au la semaine dernière au début
de la guerre en ukraine les ya eu un
petit vent de panique où les gens sont
allés dans les distributeurs retirer de
la monnaie on a pu faire un tour dans la
ville ce matin et ce n'est pas le cas
les gens n'ont pas l'air d'être dans un
mouvement de panique on sent plutôt une
certaine fatalité une fatalité notamment
quand on leur parle des sanctions et
pour cause ils ont l'impression que
c'est un mot qu'ils entendent depuis
plusieurs années on l'a vu dans le sujet
notamment d' antoine mariotti les
sanctions russes ils en ont les russes
ils en ont l'habitude donc ils
n'arrivent pas encore en ce moment en
mesurer les conséquences et puis il faut
se dire que beaucoup soutiennent
vladimir poutine et prennent ces
sanctions bien comme une attaque de
l'occident ils ne remettent pas en cause
dans cette guerre en ukraine c'est
plutôt la jeunesse russe qui s'inquiète
une jeunesse qui a connu un pays se
modernise et qui a très peur d'un retour
en arrière j'ai pu m'entretenir
notamment avec des jeunes parents qui me
disait qu'il était très inquiet pour la
remise l'avenir de leurs enfants qu'ils
avaient également peur et qui a beaucoup
de personnes se retrouvent au chômage il
faut dire aussi ici mariam qui aime
beaucoup de désinformation un peu
d'informations filtrent dans les médias
russes aucune information ne filtre mis
à part et bien ce qu'on peut appeler la
propagande du kremlin lors lors d'une
intervention du show télévisé très
important et très suivis ici en russie
bien le présente à dire a dit l'occident
montre son vrai visage il ne sanctionne
pas poutine ou encore les oligarchies et
sanctionnent le pulp le russe nous
n'avons jamais vu un tel niveau de haine
donc difficile aujourd'hui pour les
russes d'avoir les informations et les
conséquences éventuelles de ces
sanctions
merci beaucoup julie